Jet lag.
Well, it's time to wake up and learn a little bit about jet lag.
Over 90% of people who travel through three time zones...
...experience symptoms of jet lag which include...
...insomnia, fatigue, constipation, poor concentration, irritability and depression.
There is no treatment and recovery may take up to two weeks.
But here are some tips for minimizing its effect.
If flying from east to west, exercise in the sunlight in the late afternoon.
If flying from west to east, exercise in the sun in the mid-morning.
Talk to a physician about using a mild sleeping aid...
...such as Ambien or Sonata...
...if you are taking a red-eye flight from west to east.
Over-the-counter antihistamine such as Benadryl have also been used with some success.
My personal favorite is melatonin, which is a naturally occurring hormone...
...that's been linked to the control of the human circadian rhythm.
Dosage varies from 2 to 5 milligrams...
...taken about 30 minutes before normal bedtime on the day of travel,...
...and then 1/2 a milligram each day for 4 days after arrival at your destination.
Other recommendations include drinking lots of fluids,...
...reserving a window seat, watching a boring movie or...
...enjoying a spa or massage treatment after arrival.